قالها وزير الخارجيه الصينيه
علاقات بلاده مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تواجه تحديات خطيره بسبب
استمرار ما سماه عناد واشنطن في رؤيه
بيجين كمنافس رئيسا له وعرب الوزير الصيني
عن رفضه مسمها المنافسه الصفريه مع امريكا
مشيرا الى نصين ستحافظ على الاستقرار
الاستراتيجي في علاقاتها مع الدول
وهي تقوم على التعاون وعدم المواجهه وعدم
استهداف طرف ثالث
وزير الخارجيه الصينيين بشده سياسه
الولايات المتحده الخاطئه الصين
وتاتي تصريحاته وزير الخارجيه الصنيف في
اعقاب استياء الصين امس السبت
والتعميرها عن غضبها ومعارضتها التامه
لقانون تفويض الدفاع الوطني الامريكي الذي
اعتمده الرئيس الامريكي جيفايدن الجمعه
ويزيد المساعده العسكريه
ان القانون يشمل بنودا تحدث ضررا خطير
للسلام والاستقرار في مضيقي تايوان
ورد في بيان الوزاره ان القضيه تتجاهل
الحقائق لتضخيم تهديد الصين وتتدخل بشكل
تعسفي في الشؤون الداخليه الصين
الصيني وهو ما يمثل استفزازات السياسيه
خطيره